but you're the funny thing is the
democrats it's it's always been the
democrats
always what's up with the hell you know
well this whole
you know theory that oh the party
switched
no they didn't do they did not i got to
go in for you go ahead
uh did you do you see that trump
announced he might deliver his
acceptance speech at gettysburg
wow really yeah so trump said maybe two
locations the white house
and or gettysburg and
it's really funny this this this
journalist this progressive journalist
tweeted
why would you hold a an acceptance
speech at the place your side
where your side lost and i responded the
republicans wanted gettysburg
yeah yeah abraham lincoln was a
republican yep the democrats were
the confederacy yeah so trump's a
republican yeah what is that what does
that mean
and so now they're there there is
hilarious there's journalists coming out
slamming trump
saying things like uh you know he's
always been
a fan of the you know a defender of
confederate names and traditions or some
other nonsense
and people are like people are like you
you think that him giving a speech
at a site of a great defeat of the
confederacy is him
honoring the confederacy yeah have they
ever heard the gettysburg address do
they
it's yeah i know what dude
i think it i think it's crazy it's
embarrassing you know what getting
really embarrassing to watch
news oh totally i mean i i don't i don't
watch news
i get clips of it from people going wow
here they go again and i'm like
it's ridiculous do you see the the thing
about brian stelter of cnn
what about it when he was like can you
believe that there's a whole media
network dedicated to just ragging on
biden
and then he he actually asked okay i i
could get i could be getting this wrong
but my understanding is that he asked
one of the guests
could you imagine a network like that
you know just dedicated to talking about
trump
and she says no there isn't one or
something like that that is
that and i was like cracking up i still
am cracking up whenever i hear it said
out loud
it is funny yeah that's funny yeah yeah
and my favorite part about it was that
he he highlighted a statement from ben
shapiro okay
and it was ben shapiro saying something
like um you know biden is falling apart
he's literally falling apart
and that was it and he was like this
hate in this vitriol and i was like he
he barely said anything dude what are
you you know i was thinking about this
the other day
what if i know this is kind of far
far-fetched and it doesn't have anything
to do with this but what if
it was all a ploy what if biden is
is still sharp and that's what i was
saying before and he's just like
leaning into this old man thing
bro yeah you said it william comes on to
the debate yes willy wonka when he comes
out he doesn't
flip yeah he's like i'm ready biden's
gonna
he's gonna come out in a wheelchair with
a blanket on his lap and then he's gonna
he's gonna get up and he's gonna be
shaking
and they're gonna be like oh man and
he's gonna fall over everyone's gonna
gasp he's gonna do a perfect somersault
pop up and go
and he's gonna walk up strong as an ox
and he's gonna be like listen you're fat
i'm gonna talk to you about a million
different progressive policies i'm gonna
be enacting donald trump's got nothing
on this
people are gonna be like whoa i wish and
then he's gonna turn around into his
jacket
no people are gonna notice he got a long
pinky fingernail
and there's gonna be pictures of his
pinky nail and they should periodically
be like
i gotta fix my teeth oh yeah or just a
little precarious uh pinky ring
i think opens so i i i made this as kind
of like a half joke
you know because he talked about
choosing susan rice as his vp
yeah right and i'm like why is because
she is is it because she's about to be
indicted by durham
probably and then if they try to indict
her they're going to be like he's
interfering in the election we coming
after
his vice president i think it's
hilarious that joe biden is accused of
serious wrongdoing with with the ukraine
scandal yeah and his son
and barisma and all the stuff and
they're like but you know he's just he's
the
potential candidate i don't care yeah
who cares
so that we have him with the allegations
of of you know ukraine gate but we've
got him spying on
on the trump campaign using government
we definitely sources we definitely see
the full report
but okay what we can say right now is
according to these notes
it would appear joe biden was in this
meeting and floated using the logan act
which has never been used before against
an american
to jam up and sabotage the incoming
administration yeah
and he went on tv and claimed he didn't
know anything about the prosecution of
flynn
his name is on as one on the list of one
of the people who requested the
unmasking of flynn right what that means
is
flynn they they were spying on phone
calls
and they have to redact the name of
american citizens because of the fourth
amendment
so joe biden said i want to know whose
name that is that's unmasking yeah
that means that the us government was
spying on they were spying on the
russians
but because flynn was on the phone with
them they joe biden was like i want to
know who that american was
and then they decided to use the logan
act against it's ridiculous the logan
act is nonsense
it's it's never been used it was an
archaic law from like the early
foundation of the country
it basically says you can't repres you
can't claim to represent the us
government
but the reason it's insane is because he
was the
adviser to the president the incoming
the president-elect
yeah and they tried to claiming that he
couldn't what that's ridiculous like
wasn't that his
actual job right now it seems like
yeah they definitely i mean look man the
texts between peter struck and lisa page
our insurance policy we won't let it
happen yeah come on man
i'm not gonna let it happen yeah he's
not gonna win we won't let it happen
yeah wait what and then the russiagate
scandal and the investigations and the
waste of time
yeah it seriously bogged his presidency
down for the past
three years basically for his entire
presidency he's been dealing with
these lies of russiagate so what he's
founded in nothing so what do you think
happens if he gets reelected
he's he's dropping the hammer political
nuke oh yeah
the equivalent of a nuclear bomb in the
political world yep yeah
and i think that's why they're willing
to go to any lengths
any i think it's funny man trump said he
was going to lock hillary up
you know yes he did he did say that and
everybody wondered why isn't he why
isn't he going for locking up hillary
right now because he's playing
40 chess baby maybe oh yeah dude he is
he's a calculating dude he's smart
maybe it was he wanted to get as much as
he could done in his first four years
before going nuclear
yep probably we don't know what's going
to be in that durham report we don't
really know
i can't wait to see what that oh i can't
wait to read that
hey man you might be disappointed maybe
i'll warn everybody this
i i sat through this all of these
lefties going like oh man when the
mueller report comes out it's going to
be the bomb it's going to drop it's
going to do everything
trump's done the walls are closing in
bombshell bombshell bombshell the
mueller report drops and
nothing well rachel maddow was crying
he said it was breathtaking yeah trump
said it was breathtaking what he's seen
did you see the video of rachel maddow
almost crying
no she denies it but there's a really
funny video of a woman watching tv and
it looks like rachel maddow's about to
cry
what was she watching she's watching
rachel maddow so it's like
rachel maddow's on tv and this woman
films herself watching it and she's like
she's crying
she starts laughing i thought you were
saying that rachel maddow was sitting in
a room
watching herself and crying while
watching herself cry i was like this is
a weird image how did this is
i assume most people know she is but
she's the host of an msnbc show and
she's been one of the biggest
cheerleaders of trump russia
like there's a famous segment rachel
maddow did where she's like
russia could turn off the power in fargo
in the winter
okay you're warning people that they
might get their electricity shut off by
russia
that's that's how crazy she was and and
then msnbc had a guy who claimed that
trump may have been a russian asset
since the 80s
these people lost the plot a long time
ago yeah they did and then the report
came out
and man did the color drain from their
faces
well there was nothing oh everything
they put out was lies
yep then recently we got the transcripts
from all of these people like i think
brennan and whatever these people who
appeared on tv
and then privately they testified we
have no evidence we don't know if it's
true but
they were saying we have all this we
haven't seen it it's true
so much evidence that's blah blah blah
blah blah that's all it is
it was all fake news yes so i say this
because right now you got everybody
going oh man the durham report
oh it's coming they're investigating
them then it's going to come out and
it's going to be like
i think to be fair there's a reason to
believe it's going to be bigger
than the mueller port for sure because
yeah it turned into a criminal
investigation
i know which means it's that sounds like
indictments
two different attorney generals are
looking into it
you know we got the one in texas i
forget is it the name doesn't um
ring ring a bell but i mean ag bar
sent two different people to investigate
from two different angles
yep so that i mean there's there's
enough that they needed two different
people on it to go you know that's it's
it's gonna be spicy the other day i
tweeted bill barr is rap yeah i saw that
because
he i i heard this i heard a statement
about him talking about antifa and i was
just like
rad i was like bill barr's rad yeah uh
there's i'm sure that
i'm sure we can go back in time there's
a lot of things i disagree with him on
but you know
the context of it was he's targeting
these extremists these vandals
these destroyers and i thought it was
rad that he was doing it yeah and then
today i saw this far left
uh reporter main stream hundreds of
thousands of followers
impeach billbar oh my gosh and i saw
that i was like
and then and then the comments were like
the comments were like
they had him testify because they're
investigating him and i'm like oh shut
up you people are nuts
yeah what's funny is they say this it's
it's a mirror world
it's just absolute shooter but what we
say it's a mirror world to what they say
that's true we say the democrats invited
her evil they say trump and the
republicans are evil
we say we got to investigate them for
the crimes they say trump's got to be
investigated for the crimes
that's why i'm telling people don't get
your hopes up yeah you know you know
life life can be disappointing sometimes
but we'll see i think i think we might
have an october surprise
i don't know i don't know if it'll
matter i think so too but will it matter
i think so
i i don't think anything the democrats
do it's gonna change
the americans out there that are sick of
all of it they're sick of the media
they believe trump is their champion and
i i believe it too
and they're gonna go they're gonna go
vote they're gonna go out and vote
nothing is gonna stop them from going
out and voting
yeah but mail in voting cheating
okay all these weird games are playing i
mean this we're we're going into it
knowing you know it's like he the
president is is calling them out
we're being investigated like we're
we're going we're going after this stuff
so it's not like we're going to be
caught blindsided
we see it happening in front of us we're
talking about it we're letting the world
know and hopefully you guys are all
sharing this
we have a super chat from kevin mccarthy
says tim the flynn call was not unmasked
comey already had it that is what makes
it so bad there was another surveillance
either illegal or authorized directly by
potus and ag
well so there was unmasking but it may
be if if kevin here
is is correct that they there was other
surveillance i have heard that
i don't know you know i can't say i can
confirm it yeah there was a report there
was there were documents
released showing who had made unmasking
requests so
for whatever reason man i don't know
perhaps there's a lot more to this than
we realize
i mean look the dnc was accused of
colluding with certain russians to jam
up the trump campaign it's a fact yep
it was reported by politico the new york
times a court in ukraine
ruled that ukrainians were meddling in
the u.s election
now they they claim in the media it's
fake news it's a lie it's like uh
what you know the craziest thing is
politico ran the story
that democrats were the dnc was
colluding with ukrainians
and then politico ran the other story
claiming it was fake news
and so i i specifically tweeted out i'm
like okay politico retract your story
then and they wouldn't do it and i'm
like pick one
they can't both be true right and they
would not do it
because they don't care because they
were both getting clicks i don't know
i guess because both reporters were like
nope it's true and i i it's a dirty game
these these media people are playing yes
it is
yeah man let me let me actually see if i
can uh so i just wanted to say
so i was talking to my grandmother today
uh call your grandmother
by the way if you haven't called her
lately you should do that call your
grandmother
so i was talking to her she's awesome
she's she's surprisingly
i i i guess it's not really surprising
because like the older you get the more
you you pay attention to all this stuff
she's she's she's like a firecracker
with all the stuff like we were just
shooting the
the political commentary back and forth
but she i think she's got a little crush
on
on a g bar she's like she's like yeah
he's a straight shooter but talking
about that
and if she is watching sorry for for
blasting you out but i think he's here
he's calm dude check this out
i love highlighting this ukrainian
efforts to sabotage trump backfire
kiev officials are scrambling to make
amends with the president-elect after
quietly working to boost clinton
january 11 2017 kenneth p vogel i
remember this
yeah but apparently it's fake news now i
guess i mean didn't ukraine just
unmask biden he was on a report in
january
but it was redacted and they unredacted
it like last month
saying that's actually the the
mysterious american
that they were dealing with is actually
joe biden i don't know
uh i don't know about that i mean i do
know who knows what like
we're we're seeing this like what is
fake what is real you know
you know that's constantly the battle
we're dealing with joe biden's son was
on the board
of a of a ukrainian energy company his
son has
no doesn't speak ukrainian no no no uh
expertise in the energy field and he was
getting paid by some estimates eighty
three thousand dollars per month
wow that's a lot for what for what
access to the vice president mm-hmm
exactly and then then
like were you about to do the china oh
no well i was about to go ahead
you go i was gonna say joe biden has
that famous viral video where he's like
you know so i told him fire the
prosecutor oh yeah you know
otherwise you're not getting the money
and they said you can't do this i'd talk
call the president let him know
and then he's like if he's not fired and
you know in six hours or whatever you're
not getting the money
he's like well i'm not going to say
because it's youtube we're family fun
son of a gun
he got another gun yeah he got fired and
everyone said oh it's
normal that we tie you know you know
diplomatic request and i was like
wait it's normal that the u.s bribes a
foreign government to fire a prosecutor
in exchange for billions of dollars
right that's kind of weird to me
regardless i agree but no that's fine
it's fine
if if the u.s and its interests are
willing to say we'll give you billions
if you fire your prosecutor fine
the crazy thing about that whole story
with joe biden is that
he claims the prosecutor was corrupt and
wasn't
doing the investigations so he had to go
the only problem is the new prosecutor
who came in
cleared this uh the barisma guy of all
wrongdoing
and then when trump came in the dude
fled to monaco oh
interesting i didn't know that yeah
interesting sounds like joe biden is
dirty
tell you what here's what i want you to
do everybody you want to figure this out
not right now but eventually when your
time
you go you go to google right you type
in joe biden or you type in biden
corrupt
but you go to the tools section on
google
then you go to it says anytime you click
that click custom range
and set it for 2015 and earlier
boy will you find lots of articles about
joe biden being corrupt
from the washington post from political
from all these outlets really yup
talking about his family the soft
corruption how he uses his political
positions to grant them all favors and
get them access the mysterious ways that
his kids make money and his brother
makes money
and then as soon as we enter the
political space joe biden is not corrupt
everyone
joe biden is great there is no
corruption and then
didn't he get put in some board for like
some billion dollar company in china or
something hunter i'm talking about
hunter biden
he flew on air force two for a private
equity deal in china i don't know
the issue with chinese you got to
understand is that they'll try and say
oh but it was
a private company and it's like every
company in china
is the communist party of china that's a
good point it is
not and if it was a private company with
a in a private deal why was he flying on
air force two
why yeah why are they using taxpayer
resources for this sort of stuff yeah
now i'll be fair i
you know definitely fact check me on all
this stuff this is not something we had
pulled a bunch of sources on or anything
like that but yeah but seriously
shooting the breeze
you start looking into this stuff and
you start going huh
like trump has weird stuff too trump you
know cheating his wife
there's like there was a weird report
where the air force was using trump golf
resorts like staying in scotland
but like as much as you can say why is
this enriching trump is trump using this
to pay himself
you could also argue is trump saving the
us government money
by having them use his properties
instead of using expensive third parties
yeah it's not like he has to pay for it
i do i do have a problem with it though
i think it's it's poor tact
even even if he has given the u.s
government a discount he's he spends
there's a lot of money spent on trump's
you know golfing trips
we've talked about that it's like and
and we mentioned it earlier it's like he
didn't come in and become the president
and
and act presidential he wasn't a
politician for his whole life
you know he went from being a celebrity
really with the apprentice of 20 years
basically since 2000 2004 they started
the apprentice
it went all the way till basically he
was like all right i'm gonna run for
president
so he went from that celebrity status to
becoming the president
now you see him really maintaining his
composure now he's not he doesn't
understand the political game
he does now he's right he's battling
he's had a crazy crash course over the
past four years
so this this would make sense if you
give trump the benefit of the doubt
then you can imagine a scenario where
they're like we're having a bunch of
you know air force men flying you know
to europe they're going to be stopping
in scotland
and then trump is like have them stay at
my resort put them up it'll be great
they'll love it yeah it's going to be
luxury these guys deserve it
and he thinks he's doing a discounted
favor by saying like yeah you use my
company's properties
but it looks improper because the money
still goes there
and there was there there was talk i
can't remember exactly what it was he
talked about
you know having his property do like a
big i think it was like the g20 or
something or the g7 okay
and people were like regardless of
whether or not he provides a discount
that's going to cover costs for his
business so it it's
it like it's not about profit that's why
that's why i say he
it's tactless he shouldn't have done
this okay and and maybe you're right
maybe he didn't realize he thought he
was doing a good thing
or but what if what if the taxpayers
were actually
given the the actual numbers saying all
right so say we didn't use
trump's businesses say we chose i don't
know whatever
the hilton you know the top hilton hotel
and it cost three million dollars to do
it there
yes just a broad number but it only
costs 1 million
using trump's resort the argument is
that if his business is failing
by covering costs through taxpayer
dollars he's saving himself
so even if he doesn't make a profit and
provides a discount it's a benefit to
his company and his family
okay so that's why i'm like you
shouldn't have done it and apparently
did it more than once
but but what am i supposed to say you
know barack obama killed an american kid
he killed a six-year-old american
citizen am i supposed to complain about
trump putting up air force men in a
luxury
you know trump golf resort it's not on
the hot it's not a high priority for me
no
though i will criticize it and i did
when he did it and i'll do it now
i look at joe biden using air force two
to fly to china for private equity deals
putting his kid on the board of barisma
and i'm like okay okay hold on man yeah
trying to get you know
these favors and stuff like this i i can
criticize trump within within certain
bounds and be like he should not have
done that
and i think it should be criticized but
you got to look back at the decades of
joe biden
oh yeah and the dnc and so that's why i
always say
i have never been a big fan of trump i
think he's a funny guy as a personality
entertainer i think he's awesome
you know i think his show his character
everything he's built he's fantastic
as a president i think he lacked
professionalism he's made a lot of
mistakes
but he is infinitely better than joe
biden who is a disaster a nightmare and
will lead this country to ruin
that's a little strong so we should talk
about the riots in that regard too i
think i think a lot of the mistakes that
he made
were were people trying to sabotage him
in in many different ways you got bolton
for example just this
warmonger you know that and then the we
we even talked about how he came in and
because of russiagate he couldn't even
fire everybody
that he knew was dirty so he actually
had to work with a lot of these people
like you you've told me this yourself
you know so he had to work with these
people
because he couldn't get rid of them
because then they would have been like
oh see he's trying to get rid of the
evidence because of russiagate which we
now know isn't true
so it's like a lot of these these
problems that he's had to deal with
he's risen above he has cleaned up his
act man he really has
well and and he's cleaning up the people
around him which
you yourself told me he he had no choice
in the matter take a look at this
article
take pull it up you want to read it sure
bleeding john bolton stumbles into
capital building claiming that iran
shot him it's from the onions it's
satire but
it's so good oh man here's what they
wrote
bursting through the congressional
chamber doors while moaning and
clutching his shoulder john bolton
reportedly stumbled into the capitol
building
claiming he'd been shot by iran help
help i've just been attacked by a large
middle eastern country
around 636 thousand square miles in size
said the national security adviser
telling those assembled that he'd just
been minding his own business
when an aggressive islamic republic had
thrown him on the ground and shot him
with a long-range missile
right right right after iran shot me i
heard the nation laugh and say somebody
stop me before i go on a homicidal
rampage
it was acting crazed and irrational and
i could smell enriched uranium coming
from one of its urban centers
please hurry if we move quickly we might
still be able to catch it before it's
too late
upon further questioning bolton admitted
that the incident had happened so fast
that it was possible he'd been attacked
by venezuela or north korea
this is a joke and it's remarkable to me
that the onion writes this because
it is it is very uh is very esoteric in
terms of
if you understand foreign policy and you
know you're into politics yeah john
bolton's a warmonger
clearly so the onion amazing
amazing yeah trump made a mistake bring
that guy on and i think people warned
him about it
he's made a lot of mistakes you know but
i i i think
when i look at trump i'll put it this
way it started with
stop making me defend trump right yep
and
it was like dude dude hold on that's not
true you're making that up
oh tell me the story you said earlier
are you leading into that no no
no no talking about no that's private oh
okay yeah yeah yeah but i'll
i'll i'll clarify just wait i'm talking
sum it up sum it up you can just people
hitting me up telling me
that like they really do love trump and
they're
they're scared to talk about it but
what's what's triggering their kind of
like
opening up to trump is that the media
claims everything he does is wrong
everything and at a certain point
someone's got to say something like well
it's not possible a broken clock is
right twice a day right yeah so where
the two times you're gonna
nope never they look into it and turns
out
they end up liking him yeah and i think
a lot of people end up giving him
giving him the benefit of the doubt when
they realize that how much the media
lies
there's so many famous instances i'll
give you a light one first
when donald trump was with shinzo abe of
japan
and they're like throwing food into the
koi fish pond oh yeah then all of a
sudden the camera zooms in on trump and
he dumps the whole thing in
and then everybody makes fun of him
they're like oh no he's so
dumb turns out someone at abc i think
was abc or
some news outlet edited the video in the
full context
shinzo abe throws all the food in and
then trump shrugs and then does the same
he was following the lead of the prime
minister and they misframed it to make
him look bad
of course you know what the craziest
thing was what when a woman on msnbc
said trump was discussing
he was talking about exterminating
latinos what okay do not
trump has never gotten anywhere near to
saying anything like that
what in fact quite the opposite trump
took a picture of himself eating a taco
bowl at trump tower saying he loved
mexicans
that's true so it's like the exact
opposite okay yeah
that's how crazy it's gone taco bowls
are good you gotta admit they're they're
good
let me see if i can find the this is
this is crazy
no joke msnbc's nicole wallace
apologizes for saying trump was talking
about exterminating latinos
i misspoke they say about lies man
the lie travels halfway around the world
before the truth can strap on his boots
so she goes on and she says this it
freaks everybody out and nobody hears
the correction
nope they just spread it around now it's
probably a meme
this is a news meme spreading around on
facebook it's one of the craziest things
i've ever seen happen
in politics that's nuts yeah man yup
she should be she should have been fired
for that let me let me tell you
something
there have been many instances where
trump has been correct
and that's led me to a point where i'm
like i've always tried to view things
rationally and fairly
so when i watched antifa acting a fool
and i've seen i've witnessed it i'm like
they're acting a fool
when donald trump comes out and says
something i don't immediately say oh my
god i can't believe you said that i say
let me look into the source and see
what's going on oh that was fake news
like the very fine people hoax yep a lot
of people don't know this maybe
i'm assuming most of you know this trump
never claimed both sides
were all very fine people he was
referring specifically
to regular people amid a crowd of
violence i'm being relatively vague the
general idea is
trump was he specifically said i condemn
you know the neo-nazis the white
supremacists the first thing out of his
mouth
i get this a lot people are like how can
you how can you defend someone who
you know is okay that says neo-nazis are
okay i'm like did you
just go watch his speech please uh you
know what fine i'll tell you the very
first thing out of his mouth is
i condemn neo-mo totally totally
condemned totally
they should be to condemn totally and
i'm not talking about those people
i'm talking about the it's like the
people that show up to to march for a
protest that they do believe in
yeah and then the people with the loud
speakers are just screaming
and then because you're standing there
that means you're now privy to whatever
they're screaming
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you